Moi au moins avec mon portable de merde,
pas de problème.
J’arrive pas
à tenir ma vanne jusqu’au bout.
Je me suis niqué la main.
Je vous promets que je fais pas exprès.
Ok, je la refais.
Vous attendez sagement Ernest.
Vous faites clairement
semblant d’avoir peur.
Est-ce qu’on peut jouer plus mal,
j’en sais rien.
Ecoute, je vais faire pipi, mais toi,
ne bouge surtout pas.
Je vais aller faire pipi.
C’est débile.
Ca me fait vraiment rire.
Quand je me torche le cul,
je me torche par l’avant.
Bien joué.
-Merci!
Eh, dis donc, est-ce que tu sais
comment on fait des pâtes?
Ta mère, c’est chaud!
Non, à la solitude!
J’ai trop de mal.
A la solitude!
Tu veux plus de vin?
Tu me demandes de verser à 2cm
de mon visage,
comment est-ce que tu veux que je vise?
Depuis que je suis dans cet hôtel…
Je parle comme Bruce Willis.
Remonte moi,
fais pas ta pute!
Je veux pas crever en Ardèche,
merde!
Arrête, on va crever tous les deux,
lâche moi!
J’m’en fous, je me bouffe le bras.
De toute façon tu tombes,
de toute façon c’est mort.
T’es tellement à chier qu’on l’a inventé pour toi
ce rang de Fantôme de merde,
te souviens-tu?
Sous-sous-merde,
allllllez!
Solitude, solitude, on t’encule!
Il était trop violent.
No Gringo!!!!
Es impossible!
-Si.
C’est quoi ce …? Je suis désolé.
Puppy oh! Tu fermes ta gueule.
Merde vieille carne!!!
C’est très bizarre.
En gros, il faudrait que tu fasses
quelque chose de vraiment,
vraiment, vraiment,
mais vraiment, vraiment.
Putain de merde.
Tu es mort sur le toit Mc Johns.
Tu es mort.
Je suis mort
T'es mort !
C’est parce que je parle en mono?
Je peux parler en stéréo.
Gauche, droite.
Mais au moins je suis en 3D moi.
Tu veux un café,
est-ce que tu le veux ce café?
Tu le désires.
Gustave,
on m’a dit beaucoup de bien de toi.
T’es quelqu’un de grand à l’intérieur.
La taille c’est pas…
ne laisse personne dire que t’es petit.
Une barque va aussi vite qu’un paquebot.
Enfin pas au vite,
... la barque
peut aller au final aussi vite
que le gros sexe... que le paquebot.
Je tiens à m’excuser de ça. Salut.
Quand il parlait du bateau,
c’était pour mon sexe
parce que j’ai un petit sexe en fait.
Tu prends du vin?
Nickel.
Comment ridiculiser un mec en smoking
en deux secondes.
Depuis Psychose
on a tous un peu peur des douches.
Donc t’hésites pas,
tu le malmènes comme ça.
Tu le malmènes comme ça,
Si je touche son anaconda?
Et si je touche sa grosse bite?
Oui mais du coup
je pense à un anaconda.
Alors, t’as touché sa bite?
Et dis leur de quoi prendre
de quoi nettoyer le …
Et dis leur de prendre de quoi …
Dis leur de prendre, putain!
Vous disposez très exactement
de 5 secondes pour sauver la terre.
Ca m’a fait marrer,
ça m’a fait marrer.
Oui, je sais. On avait prévu,
enfin on avait pas prévu vraiment.
Il me faut du temps,
il me faut du temps.
Depuis "Ca"
on a tous peur des clowns, tous.
Depuis quoi?
-"Ca"
-"Ca".
Depuis?
Quoi?